das ding ist nicht mal in gta habe ich
jemals einen funktionierenden money
blick gehabt und jetzt habe ich einen
reallife und er funktioniert
rolex trader eine serie über die mich
vermutlich die meisten von euch auf
youtube gefunden haben wir haben es
nicht gehandelt aktien gekauft poker
gespielt mystery boxen geöffnet und noch
vieles mehr irgendwann wurde es ziemlich
ruhig um dieses format und mittlerweile
ist die letzte folge über vier monate
her daran muss etwas geändert werden wir
haben uns eine menge gedanken gemacht
viel gearbeitet und die qualität auf ein
komplett neues level wir befinden uns
auf der zielgeraden viel spaß mit
staffel 2 von rolex trader hat jetzt
kommt jedoch eine neue folge rolex
trader vergesst also nicht den kanal zu
abonnieren um mir so dieses jahr noch
500.000 abos zu verhindern
melde dich über folgenden link bei eur
an
melde dich über folgenden link bei adobe
ich hatte ja es war ein fast und 20
jahren die ich jemals in meinem leben
verlieren warte mal kurz wie so halte
ich irgendwelchen leuten die wahrheit
ins gesicht wie so will ich dass sie bei
google anmelden und sie so zur hölle
bekomme ich dafür zehn euro ganz einfach
definiert marketing wie genau das aber
funktioniert und warum das einfach
einpacken reallife money bridge ist mit
dem man quasi unendlich geld drucken
kann erfahrt ihr in diesem video das
ganze funktioniert so man bringt einen
kunden dazu ein produkt zu kaufen und
erhält dafür eine kleine provision wie
ihr wisst benutze ich in diesem projekt
aber meine reichweite nicht was ist
unheimlich schwierig macht mit
affiliate-marketing geld zu verdienen
weil es immer nur winzige cent beträgt
sind oder nach zwei tagen suchen habe
ich endlich eine philipp marketing
programm gefunden dass keine cent
beträge bezahlt sondern richtig
ordentlich geld und zwar zehn euro für
jeden monat der über ordere
abgeschlossen die leute müssen nicht mal
ein bezahltes auto starten sondern
können einen probemonat staaten und ihn
sofort wieder kündigen sicherheit dafür
trotzdem aber 10 in welcher welt das
sinn macht weiß ich nicht alles was ich
weiß ist ich muss möglichst viele leute
dazu bringen über einen link ein
portables pro monat abzuschließen und
das ding ist genauso geht es
wahrscheinlich weiter wenn ich erst mal
alle meine freunde abgegrast habe dann
gleich teuren graben
aber was fehlt uns auf den street ich
weiß es nicht das t shirt auf die leute
denen das vertrauen wichtig
wir würden gern pullover locken lassen
natürlich wäre aber viel zu viel aufwand
wenn ich jetzt auf jeden freund
einzelnen persönlich zu gehen würde zum
glück hängig mit einem irgendwelchen
gruppen unterschreibe ich jetzt eine
genaue anleitung rein hier aber
bestätigen 60 tage orgel ist ja auch ein
neues produkt so aber hier könnte es
auch direkt wieder kündigen und das gibt
mir jedes mal zehn jungs was geht für
ein kommendes video roll ex trader und
genau diese sprachnachricht geht jetzt
an jede gruppe in der ich kurz app drin
bin bei der es mir nichts zu peinlich
ist offensichtlich und in meine insta
enge freunde story weil da erreicht eben
nur die leute die ich kenne und ich
meine gesamte community das ist
definitiv im rahmen und das wäre eine
möglichkeit die jeder hätte auch ohne
eine große reichweite zumindest das an
alle seine freunde über ins dazu
verteilen ich habe einen schwerwiegenden
fehler gemacht ich hatte einen fehler in
meinem link wo ich ein wort drin hatte
das gar nicht zu dem link gehören sollte
das bedeute die leute wurden auf die
website geleitet wo sie das probe abo
abschließen können amazon hat aber nicht
gecheckt dass die meeres geld geben
müssen sondern das geld ist jetzt
einfach verpufft schätzungsweise haben
gestern 30 leute aus meinem
freundeskreis ein probe abo
abgeschlossen aber kein cent ist bei mir
angekommen das bedeutet gestalten würden
in der stadt der unangenehme teil des
videos hat angefangen jetzt werde ich
hier leute an land und probieren sie von
einem pro monat autobild zu überzeugen
aber es geht in diesen klamotten
natürlich nicht deswegen habe ich mir
nicht nur ein prima der vorne und hinten
mit amazon und otto will bedruckt ist
geholt sondern auch diese frei kann
diese extra designt hat mit einem qr
code wo sich leute darüber für den
amazon otto will pro monat eintragen
können und ich dafür zehn euro bekommen
hallo ihr wollt den kostenlosen amazon
drogen monate könnte sofort wieder
kündigt
frag dich mal bitte einen monat
kostenlos von audible ein jungs
schließlich bitte einen monat amazon
euro pro jahr man kriegt den oracle
support wieder kündigen
schade und wenn ihr euch an meldet für
probemonat dann kostet das für euch nun
euro und ich bekomme 10 euro dafür ich
will euch gar nicht lang nerven hier ist
ein monate
direkt hier 50 meter weiter nach vorne
und dann links
wollt ihr einen kopflosen amazon otto
bonath riesig dass ich dir einen
kostenlosen amazon euro im monat mit
wenn ich zehn euro
wenn ich an welche den euro eigentlich
angemeldet hat
aber wenn ihr fragt mich zehn euro die
leute werden nach wie vor ort in die
trommel wäre insgesamt hat das so mäßig
funktioniert wir haben 70 euro
eingenommen das ist gut aber nichts im
verhältnis dazu wie viele leute wir
angesprochen haben und wie viel aufwand
das ist wir müssen es uns einfacher
machen was ich zu dem zeitpunkt noch
nicht wusste die nun folgende idee würde
in diesem projekt alles auf den kopf
stellen ich schreibe alten bekannten aus
verschiedenen gebieten die einfach mehr
leute erreichen können die ich nicht
kenne und mach mit denen ein 50/50 split
die bekommen den eigenen code in den
eigenen link und können so wieder
anfangen das in ihrer fußballgruppe in
ihrer lese gruppe zu verteilen leute
dazu zu bringen kostenlos zwischen
borken und wir verdienen beide dann kam
was geht
amazon viele tolle bilder reallife man
idlib
wenn du keine ahnung irgendwelche
gruppen mit kollegen hast dann will ich
mit dir richtig giftig machen weil dann
erstelle ich dir gerade zwei links coach
auf
dauer so hat nicht mehr das vorgestellt
das ding ist nicht mal in gta habe ich
jemals einen funktionierenden money
blick gehabt und jetzt habe ich einen
reallife und er funktioniert tatsächlich
also ist komplett gestört und jetzt
kommt's ihren spielen ich habe mir
nämlich was geisteskrank ist überlegt
abseits von rolex trailer möchte ich
euch bitten genau das zu tun wo mich auf
meine freunde gewesen klicke bitte auf
den link in der video beschreibung
meldet euch für ein amazon
monat an und kündigten sofort wieder
wenn ihr ihm kündigen wollte das ganze
dauert keine 30 sekunden ich bekomme 10
euro dafür und ich verspreche euch das
komplette geld was dabei rumkommt geht
bis zum ende des jahres für videos drauf
wir können anfangen minister wies kam zu
machen ich kann eine menge geld und
coole sachen an die community
verschenken und ich habe riesige pläne
tut mir den gefallen meldet euch bei
amazon orte mit vielen kostenlosen pro
monat an und unterstützt mich und die
videos bis zum ende des jahres
geschöpfen jetzt alle wie viel geld über
das affiliate marketing in den nächsten
sieben tagen reinkamen die personen die
am nächsten dran ist gewinnt 1000 euro
von
52.000 350 euro
41.200 105000
längere ferien jude bin am leben ist und
ob für 2000 und ich habe mir überlegt
das gewinnspiel noch auszuweiten so dass
sie auch mitmachen könnte schick mir
dazu einfach einen screenshot des
abgeschlossenen pro monat und euren
youtube namen an folgende mailadresse
und ratet in den kommentaren wie viel
geld es sein wird die person die am
nächsten dran sein wird gewinnt 1 1000
euro amazon gutschein viel spaß und
zurück zum video 24 stunden später es
ist unglaublich ich habe drei weitere
leute gesucht die das alles für mich
verteilen und mit mir quasi diese
schneeballsystemen starten ich habe
innerhalb der letzten 24 stunden 415
euro mit orgel umgesetzt ich alleine
konnte 29 proben monate innerhalb meines
freundeskreises vermitteln eine weitere
person hat sieben eine weitere 4 und
noch eine person hat einen vermittelt es
ist unglaublich jetzt heißt es das
netzwerk weiter ausbauen so dass wir
alle daran mitverdienen können ohne dass
irgendeine person etwas dafür bezahlt
krank durch mein lieber was geht was
geht oder die etwas andere anfrage für
dich heute freund und ich würde dir die
hälfte aller fünf euro anbieten
insgesamt habe ich jetzt 14 leute die
mir dabei helfen die links zu verteilen
die bekommen alle einen eigenen link
damit wir genau sehen wer wie viel
umgesetzt hat wenn jeder von denen nur
zehn leute für diesen pro monat an
bekommt werden dass 1400 euro jetzt gilt
es zu handeln auf goodwill zu hoffen und
dann sind wir hoffentlich ein stück
näher an der rolex
der große moment an dem wir erfahren ob
unser schneeballsystem tatsächlich
funktioniert ich werde amazon partner
nicht aufmachen und sehen wie viel dabei
umgekommen ist
ach du scheiße ich machen wenn ich hier
richtig jetzt ist der richtige tag ach
du scheiße wir haben heute alleine
590 euro umgesetzt wie jemand in einer
youtube werbung habe ich ein
schneeballsystem aufgezogen das
funktioniert ich habe heute 295 euro
verdient ohne einen finger zu krümmen er
ist unglaublich jetzt heißt es richtig
reinhauen die leute noch mal richtig
anfeuern und in den nächsten tagen
hoffentlich richtig ordentlich geld
umsetzen das problem ist dieses video
könnte theoretisch die letzte folge
rolex trade up sein was schlecht wäre
weil ich habe noch eine menge geplant
1100 und 70 euro heute allein haben wir
1000 170 euro filmen die ich bin am
zittern
irgendwie will das ist ja falsch tag 6
die reise geht weiter heute haben wir
1000 115 euro verschickt die leute sind
geisteskrank am hassel tag 7 und
passende zu tag 7 haben wir über 700
euro eingenommen und jetzt ab ins große
finale wie viel haben wir innerhalb von
sieben tagen mit amazon oder wie viele
verliebt es ist komplett geisteskrank
ist tatsächlich ein reallife man glück
so fühlt es sich zumindest an denn
niemand hat dafür einen cent bezahlt
außer amazon und die haben
2175 euro an mich ausgeschüttet das ist
die krasseste rolex trader folge die ich
jemals hatte was gewinn angeht ich bin
komplett amt ich verstehe das system
nach wie vor nicht freue mich aber über
jeden der über den ersten blick in der
video beschreibung einen orden pro monat
abschließen das war mit abstand die
geilste wohl ex trader folge die wir
jemals hatten es hat sich angefühlt wie
an so einem defekten cola automaten zu
stehen wo die ganze zeit kostenlos kohle
raus kommt und wir können das system
gemeinsam noch auf die spitze treiben
vergesst nicht den kanal zu abonnieren
damit wir dieses jahr noch gemeinsam auf
500.000 abonnenten diesen kanal kommen
vergess ich das video zu leiten und wir
sehen uns haben mittwoch wieder
[Musik]